so last time we talked I was kind of
like there's a baby what like we didn't
really know what to call him
now baby Oda has taken over the world we
literally have a baby baby Yoda shirt
right there see that everywhere did you
expect it to take off this month
no no it's constantly fascinating and
something I like is that the fans really
seem to own it and they're the ones
coming up with stuff they're the ones
just they're professing their love for
it is something that I haven't seen to
this scale so it's it's pretty amazing
pretty enjoyable though yeah so what's
what's next for for baby Yoda I can't
tell you that the next episode is the
next thing for him we'll see I think
people are gonna like where this goes
John and I are having just a great time
making it I mean completely honestly he
and I are just having a lot of fun
making this show it's something we enjoy
to do we show up to set every day and
just you know we're here in these Star
Wars worlds with Star Wars things going
on and we couldn't be happier so a lot
of work but it's very rewarding as
you've seen it's it's super interesting
like the pre marketing for it cuz baby
Yoda obviously wasn't in it IG 88 I was
like oh I'm gonna love ig-88 dead
immediately are we gonna see kind of a
crew forming though I can like sensitive
you're good you you're knowledgeable
person you might I don't know we'll have
to wait and see you know these stories
have a certain way of evolving but I
think people will be able to go back and
look at earlier episodes and see things
that maybe they missed the first time
it's just a fun adventure so that I
would have loved to have as a kid I'm
glad that we can be you know given as
the kids now it's and I think adults
seem to be enjoying it too so yeah it's
hit the mark it's hit the mark the right
way I think so I'm really pleased with
that yeah Cara Doon I mean I need more
of her Gina of course everybody Jean is
the best the best I know are you
directing more episodes I will be yep
I'm I really zero in on things that I
like you know I've been learning to
write these episodes and John's been a
great mentor that way so now I'm direct
episodes that I write so we'll see we'll
have to see what that means but it's
pretty fun I'm looking forward to it I'm
coming up on directing another one here
so we'll see we'll see what I learned
the first go-around and the second
go-around so hopefully you know I
improve we'll see what it what have you
learned beyond that the Sun exists a
whole lot a whole lot
I mean I've learned if you have a
fantastic crew which we do my job is you
know a lot easier but just I think
getting more into the nuance of the
story and subjects as opposed to making
things more obvious and easy and some of
the writing I did first season it's very
straight a Western and I've evolved that
hopefully based on my experience doing
it so you just got to keep learning and
training just like any Jedi and
hopefully you improve as you go I mean
you had to feel like a bagel like there
had to be nerd tears going to Mos Eisley
it was really cool but you know I don't
I don't get to that space I appreciate
that space but you know working with
George I always had to be really focused
and you know I wanted to show that place
in a different state than we had seen it
before and you know of course that means
you're gonna see many things you've seen
in the past but you know that's because
we went to Tatooine and you see those
things on Tatooine and I felt a lot
responsibility portrayed in way that was
accurate to the original so I thought
the team did an amazing job at bringing
it to life and it really felt like we
went back there so I'm loving the show
thank you so much
[Music]